because I don't know what Mark Fergus
said about that and they came back to me
yes you do I told you and I went back no
you didn't yeah I did no I didn't yeah
this went on for a little
while I and I had to reassure them that
if they'd have remembered to tell me
this I'd have remembered to tell you
guys so I got to go back about nine
months now and I actually did talk about
this at the time the source told me they
sat in on a meeting and it was when um
MGM first approaching Mark Fergus about
potentially bringing back the Stargate
franchise it was before they start
negotiating and it was then before
negotiations ended at
Christmas apparently they were just
having some plary chats about what Mark
Fergus felt about starret what he knows
about Stargate and at one point actually
somebody did mention to him Stargate
Universe and he apparently went on a 45
minute rant about what he would have
done in series three of Stargate
Universe if he'd been